Hey, is their costume
cooler than mine, is it?
What's this bit?
I don't have that
bit on my costume.
Can I get that?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Oh, I'd like to fly.
Time travel?
Is that a superpower?
I'd love to go back and fix some
of these mistakes I've made.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I think they have such a
different outlook on the world.
There's something about
opposites that attract.
I think there's
something in Ikaris
that Sersi is just drawn to.
There's something about the
way that Sersi sees the world
that Ikaris is drawn to.
I think they balance
each other beautifully
between the kind of practicality
and the duty and honor sense
that Ikaris has, balanced
between Sersi's way
that she sees
beauty in the world.
And I think that's
what keeps them kind
of learning from each other.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
God, I hate emojis.
The-- I know you--
The smiley face.
You're going really
generic on that one.
I don't know any other ones.
The sunglasses
emoji, probably.
And the sparkle emoji
to represent her powers.
For me it would
be, I think, the guy
with the stars in his eyes.
Like, a hand going
one, like number one.
The rocket.
The purple ball, where
you can talk to the beyond
because I talk to
the Celestials.
Maybe the hands because
she heals with her hands.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Well, they came quite
with a blank canvas,
and it's really 7,000 years
of us influencing them.
So who they are says a
lot about who we are.
So in casting these ten
incredible individuals,
I found unique individuals,
and hoping they
would open themselves up and
give us a sense of who they are
so we could shape the
character around who
they really are in real life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Well, I thought that the--
this was supposed to be
the great female warrior,
should fight like a
female and should have all
the grace and femininity
and that her strength
should come from that.
Ballet is very
challenging, so I wanted
to set myself that
challenge, and hard for me
because I'm a bit impatient.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I think the most
excited one is my husband.
When I met him, I was
already like 38, 39.
And he said, "Oh, I want
you to be an action hero.
Why don't you do a
movie Super Hero?"
And I'm like, "Baby,
forget about it.
That's never going to happen."
And it did.
And he's like, "See?
I told you."
Like, nothing.
And I said, "It's a big deal.
This is very
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I think the time
and place that
would have been my favorite
because the music was best,
and it was just a
really cool period
of time and a cool place, was
probably London in the 1960s.
I would live in
the medieval times
if I were able to be like
a princess or something.
I think that would be cool.
- Fair enough.
Yeah.
I think I'm going
to go to ancient China
to see my ancestors.
That would be fun.
I've got to say 5,000
years ago because not
too much things to worry about.
When things were
kind of raw and human.
There wasn't as much technology.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Surreal.
I mean, yeah, I remember
seeing you for the first time,
looking you up and down.
I think, it was really
cool, but everyone was also
kind of scoping each
other out, like, hey,
is their costume cooler
than mine, is it?
What's this bit?
I don't have that
bit on my costume.
Why have you got this bit?
Can I get that?
So it was really exciting
and funny, but the costumes
we kind of built over
a long period of time
into what's best
for the character
and also what's going to
be practical for shooting.
They're not just a, oh let's put
on this because it looks cool.
It's like OK well, how
does that one interact
with your specific superpowers?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I honestly love doing
the action sequences.
I found it very
challenging, but I've
never gotten the opportunity
to do action like that before.
And so I just, honestly
while shooting it,
those parts were challenging.
Watching it on screen,
how well it came together,
that was my favorite part.